Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Today is a chill working day.
I am low energy Doki T.
And we have Doki Amber Doge dad here today with us.
Because usually we don't get to bring him out a lot, often.
Because, you know, he takes up a lot of my head space.
So, normally he's not there often for streams.
Just because, like, you know, I have to be down here when I'm talking or when I'm streaming.
But today I feel like, you know, a rare occasion.
Since this is a Guerrilla stream, this is a little hangout stream with you guys while we're trying to be productive together.
I decided to bring him out for us today.
Yeah, he makes me feel very short and I don't like that.
I need to be tall and superior!
But today is, like, today he gets to be here.
He gets to sit on top of my head today for a more chill relaxing stream.
Okay, so before we actually start being productive...
I shall...
I shall give you guys a life update as to why I had to cancel my stream on Saturday.
I told the reason why on my member stream on Sunday.
I was like, yesterday, but today's Tuesday.
So I realized that things are a little fucky right now with my scheduling.
So on Sunday, I gave the reason why I was not available on Saturday and how I got sick.
So, basically...
So...
Not to make you guys feel alarmed, I'm okay.
Because on...
So, basically what happened is that on Friday, all I had for lunch on Friday was a giant chocolate Easter bunny.
Because I bought that giant chocolate Easter bunny...
After Easter, because it was on sale.
And I was like, oh, I haven't had a chocolate bunny in a long time.
And then it was a giant chocolate Kinder Surprise Easter bunny.
And I was like, oh my god, you know what?
This Easter bunny has been sitting here for a couple of days now.
For maybe a week or two now.
I should really eat it, you know?
I should try it out, because I haven't had it in a long time.
I haven't had an Easter bunny Kinder Surprise in a long time.
So I was like, om nom nom nom nom nom.
I was like, woah, this is actually really good.
Om nom nom nom nom.
And then I still kept eating it.
And I didn't break it open, I just chomped it down.
And I was like, oh man.
Oh, but like, I shouldn't put this in the fridge.
I might as well keep eating it.
I shouldn't.
I mean, it's there.
It would be foolish to just keep this in the fridge.
It's not going to taste as good, you know?
So I was just like, om nom.
And then, you know, there's still like a piece of chocolate left.
And I was like, oh, I don't feel so good.
Oh man, but like, it'd be such a waste to put such a tiny piece in the fridge.
I might as well finish it.
I might as well just finish it.
Makes sense.
Like, I can't just put this in the fridge.
Like, it's such a tiny piece.
And so, um, and then, you know, I did not feel so good right after.
Because that's all I ate for lunch.
I was talking to my friend while this was happening.
And then I was like, oh man, I don't feel so good.
And then my friend was like, of course you don't feel- you ate a whole chocolate Easter bunny!
And you didn't- that's all you ate for lunch.
So, let me give you a visual.
So I'll give you guys a visual on how, um, fucked up I was.
Okay, so, don't worry.
Don't worry.
So, um, I showed this on the member stream.
People in the members already know.
Like, they've already judged me, so it's okay.
So, this is how big that bunny was.
I already opened it.
You can see I was already eating it.
While I was taking, like, pictures for my friend.
I was, like, showing this to my friend.
And so this is, like, the size of it.
And then, and I got here, and I was like, I don't feel so good.
I don't feel so good.
And then, and then I got here.
I was just like, oh man, oh man.
I can't put this in the fridge.
There's just this piece left.
I can't, I can't just put this in the fridge.
There's just, look at how much there's left.
There's no reason.
And I might as well just finish it.
I might as well just finish this.
I might as well just finish the entire, all of it.
So, well, the story doesn't end here.
You think, like, oh, you had so much sugar.
So, like, on Saturday, you just didn't feel good.
Because, like, that's all you had.
Like, your tummy hurt because your entire stomach was just chocolate.
No, that's not the end of the story.
So, like, right after, for dinner, I had Dairy Queen.
Because one of my friends was, like, messaging me.
And I was like, oh my god, Doki.
Guess what?
The S'mores Blizzard is back in the menu.
And I was like, S'mores Blizzard?
And then my friend was like, yeah, that's their best flavor.
Oh my god, you gotta try it, Doki.
Oh my god.
And I was like, oh.
I was like, oh.
Oh, they say it's really good.
So, I was like, okay.
So, I ordered a S'mores Blizzard.
But not just a S'mores Blizzard.
I also ordered a Dairy Queen Chili Hot Dog.
So, like, you must be wondering, what?
Dairy Queen sells hot dogs?
Yes, and that's why you shouldn't order hot dogs from Dairy Queen.
Because...
You see, ordering a cooked meal from a place that's known for ice cream is not, like, the smartest thing to do in life.
And I learned that the hard way.
So, I...
And, like, the thing is, I don't know how long those sausages have been, like, on the grill thingy, on the rotating thing.
I mean, because I Uber Eats it.
So, like, I have no idea how long those sausages have been there for.
And...
So, you know.
And not only did I have a S'mores Blizzard with my Chili Hot Dog.
But I also had a Moo Moo Latte.
Which is basically, like, a caffeinated milkshake.
So...
Because I was like, you know what?
I should get a drink with this meal.
Because that's what you do, right?
You should always order a drink with your meals.
And I was like, ooh, Moo Moo Latte.
That sounds cute.
So, that's why streams on Saturday were cancelled.
That's why we didn't have any Saturday streams.
I was not feeling so good after that day.
I might have mixed up a lot of stuff in my stomach that day.
You know, when I woke up on Saturday, I was not feeling like a person anymore.
It was sort of like a post-sugar rush.
Post-sugar rush, I feel like I'm gonna die.
With a questionable hot dog, too.
It's not just the sugar.
It was also questionable hot dog.
Let's just say it did not go down so well in the end.
So yeah, that's why I was missing in action on Saturday and I disappeared for a little bit.
Ink Demon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, please get some food.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Medi, thank you for the super chat.
Here's some money to buy better food.
Please.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't worry, I ate real food today, though.
Don't worry, guys.
Today, we had real food.
Guys, don't worry.
No questionable meals today.
Anyway, but yeah, that was my day.
That was my Saturday.
I just wanted to let you guys know why I was missing on Saturday.
Stream schedule was going to be late because, well, I just confirmed my sponsor.
So I was wondering if I could announce it or not.
Because I'm supposed to make the official tweet on the day of the stream.
But then I was like, oh, can I just announce it early since I have a stream schedule?
And they're like, yeah, it's fine.
So I'm going to be doing a co-stream watch along on my own.
This sponsor is going to be on Twitch, by the way.
So I am going to be doing a Twitch stream and watching.
I'm going to try and see what it's called again, because sorry.
It's an official Samsung event for Samsung Galaxy Gear Cup, Gear Up Cup for the, I believe it's a Call of Duty mobile.
So Samsung is hosting a Call of Duty mobile tournament on April 25th.
And I'll be, I'm sponsored along with some other streamers to do like a watch along of the tournament itself.
Yeah.
And it's like to advertise their newest phone, like advertise their phone and stuff.
So I'll be doing it on Twitch, though.
So I have a stream on the 11th where they're doing a one hour draft stream, drafting stream.
I don't know, I'm not exactly sure what it is, but what a waste of time and money.
Not mine.
Not my money.
But yeah, that'll be on Friday.
So I know, like I said, like, oh, Min and I are going to do a collab on Friday, but we had to move that to Thursday.
So we're actually, our collab is going to be on Thursday instead, because I have my sponsor on Friday.
So I just wanted to let you guys know, because I know some of you guys are like, oh, I can't wait for Friday.
But the schedule did change, it swapped around.
So sponsor is on Friday, but that'll be on Twitch.
And then collab stream is going to be on Thursday instead.
So that's like a little update regarding that.
But yeah, that's basically what my schedule is so far.
I don't know what else to do for the rest of the week.
I'll figure that out either on the stream or later.
And then I know some of you guys are like, Toki, I thought it was over.
I thought you were done with Marvel Rivals, ranked session, the leaderboards.
Why are you... Okay, guys, you don't understand.
The badge sparkles now, guys.
Like, you don't under...
Guys, you don't understand.
The badge... Okay, no, I will...
No, you don't understand, it's shiny.
It's different.
It's the same size, which is above average.
By the way, it's above average size, okay?
But like, it's... No, no, you don't...
Okay, guys, I'm gonna show you guys real quick.
I'm gonna...
No, I refuse to let you guys judge me.
I refuse.
I refuse to let you guys judge me right now.
I'll show you why we are making the choice we are making.
Look, we're not playing, I just...
I need to show you, okay?
I need to show you guys why, and you'll understand.
You'll understand now, okay?
I refuse to be judged.
Okay.
Give me a sec, it's loading up real quick.
It'll be fast, guys.
I'm just showing the badge of why I wanted to see if I could get it this season.
Okay.
Okay, give me a sec.
I'm just...
Oh, shit, no, that's not what I...
Whoops, sorry.
Hey.
Don't judge me!
I'm in my shame.
I'm in my hidey box because you guys judged me now.
Look what you did.
I'm in my hidey hole because you guys tried to judge me.
Look at that.
Now, it won't come out.
Now, Dogekitty will never come out because of it.
Alright.
Okay, okay.
Let me show you guys.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, guys.
Okay, so this is like last season, right?
Like, last season.
It's over here.
Guys, this above average badge right here.
Okay?
Like, you understand.
Like, yeah.
It doesn't sparkle.
Look at...
Okay.
So...
Next season.
Next...
This...
This season...
It sparkles.
Oh, my God.
Look at the sparkle.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's different.
The sparkle adds more length to the badge.
Guys, it's shiny.
It adds...
It adds more length to it.
It's a must-have.
It's a must-have achievement now.
It makes it longer.
And it also sparkles.
Okay?
So this is what I...
This is the plain one that no one gives a fuck about because it doesn't sparkle.
And then you get the sparkler.
It's just a simple bird.
If it shine, I want it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Like, alright.
Look at this.
This is what I will have if I don't get top 500.
This is what I could have, guys.
It's...
Oh, my God.
It's so shiny.
Look at that.
And it looks longer.
Which, I mean...
To be fair, it's already pretty long.
It's above average.
To be...
To be fair, it's already above average.
But it could be more.
It could be...
It could be more.
There you go.
So that's why...
Guys, that's why I'm gonna try...
That's why I'm trying to see if I could make it in, guys.
Even as a man, I think the skyscope is a bit much.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look.
All I'm saying...
Not only does...
Not only...
But does yours have lightning come out?
I don't think so.
I...
I don't think so, chat.
Does yours have lightning come out?
So that's why...
That's why...
That's why we're trying again this season.
Because they made it different, okay?
They made it...
Okay, look at how boring this is.
It's just yellow.
It's so boring.
But oh my god, look at this though.
Oh, woah.
It's so different, chat.
And it's gonna look so good right here at the top right corner.
That takes up 1 18th of the space on the top right.
Oh my...
It's gonna make a big difference, guys.
It's gonna make a huge difference on my banner.
So yes, that is why...
That is why we are trying this season to see...
We have literally two days left to see if we can get it.
But I'm like 100 points away.
So like, I don't know, maybe.
But don't worry, after that...
That would be my last...
That would be the last time I try.
I swear to god.
Unless they make it even shinier.
But like, there's no way.
There's nothing else they can add to the badge that'll make it any different, chat.
Unless they change the badge.
They change the badge design.
Maybe make it a little bigger.
Which I don't mind.
I don't care.
But I don't care, to be honest.
Cause like, I think it's the perfect size.
Which is above average.
I already think it's the perfect size.
But if it does get a little bigger...
And like, there's fireworks or something.
Or if the badge starts fucking, I don't know, running around my banner.
Or...
They make it like...
They make it like, I don't know.
It starts fucking going RGB or anything.
I might come back.
I might come back to the top 500 grind.
What about fireworks, rainbow glowing?
But...
For now, this will be the last time.
I swear to god, this will be the last time.
Unless they change the badge.
And like, make it like, I don't know.
More special than the last one.
Make the badge twerk.
Unless the badge starts twerking or something.
It'll be fine.
Unless the badge starts doing the DVD logo.
Where it bounces around my banner.
Trying to hit the corner.
Maybe I'll come back to it.
But for now, that'll be the last time.
I swear to god.
It's just cause it's sparkling.
It's just cause it's that sparkly and shiny.
That's why I really want to get it.
That'll be it.
I swear to god.
But yes, that is why I'm trying again for this season.
I only have two days left.
I'll most likely be playing off stream for the last two days.
Just cause like, stream snipers.
And I am playing with like, an Iron Fist player.
So like, you know.
Most likely just, you know, pan his Iron Fist when he's streaming.
Cause it has happened before.
But yes, anyway.
Time to actually be productive.
Honey, thank you for the five get the shits.
Thank you, thank you.
Momohaku, thank you for the super chat.
How do we make Doki fall into the rabbit hole more, guys?
Give some sparkles to our badge.
You genius!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Look, look.
Okay.
I am a simple cat slash bird.
If it shines, I'm in.
That's all it takes for me.
Annoying, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
I really appreciate it.
What else did I write down regarding like...
Oh yeah!
Oh my gosh.
I did like...
I was doing a Hong Kong fan meet on...
Oh my god, what day was it?
On Saturday.
It was super cute.
I was actually very surprised.
I talked about it in my member stream, but 80% of the people there at my fan meet for my meet and greet, just my meet and greet, but there's a lot of people there at my fan meet as well.
My panel slash...
My panel there or slash fan meeting.
But my meet and greet was like 80% women.
And I was so surprised because my YouTube demographics does not say that.
So I was like, oh my god!
Oh my god!
The demographics was wrong!
My analytics was wrong!
Oh my god, there's so many women here to see me!
Yippee!
Oh my god.
That made me super happy because I was like, oh!
Doki for all ages and genders.
Ladies!
I'm not just a dude bro!
I'm also for the ladies.
God, I love ladies.
Oh, not all ages.
13 and up, please.
13 and up.
Anyway, women are real?
Oh yeah!
And then there was a dad!
A dad came to my...
An actual...
Not Doki Aberdoj.
But like an actual...
An actual dad-dad came to my meet and greet.
And then he was like, oh my god, I love watching you.
You like make me...
You make me so happy and stuff like that.
I was like, aw!
That's so sweet!
Oh my god!
See?
Doki for all...
No.
Doki for 13 and up ages.
Yippee!
Right up to 15%.
Thank you for the super chat, Zero.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Yeah!
But yeah, he was like, oh yeah.
It was so sweet because he was like, oh yeah.
I was like really...
I was really in a rough place in my life.
And then I started watching you.
And then you helped me be so happy.
And cheered me up during some worse moments in my life.
And I was like, oh!
Thank you!
That makes me really happy.
That I helped a lot of dragons get past some rough patches in their life.
Like, and...
Despite...
See?
Despite the age.
Despite the age, I am...
I...
What's that word?
I'm trying...
I am appropriate for all...
For 13 and up ages.
I...
So, yeah.
That made me really happy.
That like, you know, a lot of people from different backgrounds.
Different parts in their...
Different stages in their life still enjoy my content.
PG 13 and up.
Yeah, if you're under 13, your parent has to watch me.
You have to have a parental...
Parental figure there beside you to watch me.
And also subscribe to me.
Doki is generational.
But, yeah.
That's basically...
That's why I love doing these, like, conventions.
And...
I love doing the conventions and, like, meet and greets.
And fan meets around the world.
Because I love meeting my dragons from around the world.
And being able to talk to everybody.
And being able to, like, interact with you guys.
Like, one on one.
And get to know more about each of you guys individually.
In a more personal manner.
I know it's, like, really hard to get my meet and greet tickets.
But...
I hope that...
I hope to keep doing the meet and greets and stuff.
Every year.
So, like, more and more dragons have an opportunity to meet me.
Yeah.
And be able to talk to me and stuff.
Which is nice, you know?
I always love talking to you guys individually, too.
But, yeah.
This was really fun.
I love doing these types of conventions.
I do a lot of them.
I am, like, trying to not do too much this year.
Because I got, like...
It was...
I was so fully booked last year.
Like, I feel like I had a convention...
A convention every month.
Two conventions almost every month.
And I was, like, so tired last year.
So, I'm trying to do less this year.
Just so I can keep up my energy throughout 2025.
Yeah.
I went hard.
Because I never...
I never had this much of an opportunity to do conventions before.
It was really difficult to be picked, in a way.
So, like...
To be picked to be able to do a convention.
So...
Because it's, like...
Like, you know...
Management picks for you and stuff.
So, you know...
You obviously don't have a choice if you can or can't do it.
So, that's why I'm, like, really happy to be able to actually do so many conventions.
And meet so many of you guys.
Without having to, like...
You know?
Without any, like, sort of restrictions and stuff.
Because I basically make my own rules regarding how the convention...
Like, my panel goes.
And how many people I want to meet.
And, like, the time.
I actually get to pick the time limit, too.
Regarding meet and greets.
And I try to do it for at least...
My personal request is that I always want to do...
For meet and greets, I always want it to be at least two minutes.
Because I think one minute is a little too short.
Sometimes, one minute does get through.
But then I would be like...
Oh, next time, if you want me as a guest, I will want to have at least two minutes.
To be able to talk to my fans.
I don't really care about the pricing.
I just want two to three minutes to talk to my fans.
So they get to talk to me longer.
Especially if it's a paid meet and greet.
I don't mind it.
And I'd rather be able to talk to more...
I know you talk to less people.
But I'd rather have each person have a better...
Have a more memorable opportunity to have a one-on-one talk with me.
Than talking to more people in one hour.
And I usually always go over time too.
It is very tiring too.
Because I remember sometimes I would go one hour over time.
And I'd be super tired at the end.
But I feel like it's worth it.
It's worth it.
Because you guys paid to see me.
And a lot of people might be their first time talking to their Oshi.
So I want to make it a more memorable time.
In general.
So yeah, it's quality over quantity.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's why I do a lot of these appearances.
Just because like, you know.
I like just hanging out with my Dragoons a lot.
And, you know.
YouTube means not forever.
So, I never got a chance to see my Oshi Daft Punk at his...
At their...
I know what it was like.
To never be able to see your Oshi.
Before they retired.
I never got the opportunity.
I never got to see Daft Punk do their...
Go on their World Tour concert.
Before they disbanded.
I never got to do it.
You don't understand.
Their World Tour concert was beautiful.
And I was...
And I never got a chance to see it live in person.
And then I was like, when I get a little older.
I'll be able to afford to see their World Tour concert when they do their next one.
But I didn't know.
There will never be a next one.
There was never a next one.
I was so...
I was like, after their last World Tour concert.
And their fucking Giant Pyramid DJ set up.
I was like, next time I'm gonna be there.
I will be there in the audience to see this live.
Little did Pastor Hebert knew.
There was never a next time.
There was...
So...
So like, I don't want you guys to experience that too.
So that's why I do a lot of...
I do a lot of these meet and greets.
And a lot of these...
I do a lot of these conventions.
So you wouldn't get to experience the pain I had.
When I...
When I was not old enough.
To be able to afford to see the Daft Punk World Tour concert.
Not knowing it was the last one.
Bro, they're like 60 or something.
I don't want...
I said Toma.
Oh my god.
I know their real names too.
Yeah, they're like 50.
Okay.
They're like 50, but there's still a chance.
There's still...
Docs.
That's right.
Guy Manuel and Toma.
I know their real names.
That's how much of a fan I am.
Not the docs.
Gabbit, what do you mean?
You're here forever with us.
You're right.
You're gonna be in your retirement home.
Still watching.
Still watching me.
Thank you for the...
Because I'm eternal.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Gabbit.
Burrito, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, we all saw the Pokemon collab.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's why it's PG-13.
It was all PG-13, guys.
But yes.
I'm thinking about Daft Punk right now.
Because I saw the Fortnite rumors.
That Daft Punk is gonna be the next guest for the concert.
For the Fortnite concert.
And like...
That's all.
I'll take anything.
Guys, I'm that desperate.
I will fucking watch a Fortnite concert of Daft Punk.
I know it's not the same, guys.
But like...
I'll take anything I can get, guys.
I will...
Thank you for the crumb.
Oh my god.
This will feed me for 10 more years.
A little small crumb for me.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
That will feed me for 10 more years.
Thank you so much, Daft Punk.
Oh my god.
We're gonna feast.
It shall be a national holiday.
For the great news.
For all Daft Punk fans around the world.
But yes.
Apparently...
I was like researching the leaks.
And...
I was researching the leaks.
And they said it's gonna be on June or something.
And I'll be there.
I will be there.
I will be taking the...
I will make my own private lobby of the concert.
Just to see...
It's only me.
It will just be me and Daft Punk.
Watching the concert together.
I will be there.
No matter what.
I swear to god.
It won't be like the Eminem concert.
Where it fucking crashed.
The moment...
The moment he starts singing.
And then it crashed.
Oh my...
That was so sad.
This time it will be different.
It will be different, guys.
I will be able to watch the entire concert.
For those who don't know.
I am a Daft Punk superfan.
How much of a superfan am I?
Well, I would buy almost all their...
When they first opened their Daft Punk website.
And I would buy a majority of the merch on their website.
So like...
Their launching...
I remember their launch products.
Was like the Daft Punk belt buckle.
And then there's posters and everything.
And I even bought...
Daft Punk did like an original art gallery show.
In somewhere...
I don't remember where it was.
But there was an original art gallery show.
Of like different artists that Daft Punk reached out to.
To draw like different illustrations of them.
For an art gallery.
And I didn't buy the original print.
The original, original print.
But...
I bought the official like canvas print.
Of one of their Daft Punk paintings.
Of Guy Manuel.
Because I like Guy Manuel more than Tama.
I'm sorry.
His helmet was just so much cooler.
And it cost...
It was...
And I remembered...
I saved...
I like...
At that time...
I saved up a lot of money for it.
I literally like...
It was like a lot of money.
Because it was...
It might have been a thousand dollars.
It was...
It was a thousand dollars for an original canvas print.
Of one of the art gallery pieces.
Because they only sold a limited of 50.
Of the canvas print.
And then I had to have it.
No, you don't understand.
Let me...
I'll show you guys.
I still...
It's like locked up in a box somewhere.
Because I was gonna...
I'm gonna display it again.
I have a picture of it when I displayed it in my apartment.
But like...
Okay, let's see.
Daft Punk art gallery.
Alright, let me show you guys.
I shall...
I'll show you.
Oh, I still remember.
It was NME.
I think that was it.
And like...
I had...
I used...
I displayed it when I first got it.
But...
Oh my god, it's this one.
Oh my god, I still...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I remember it.
They actually have it in...
It's called the Rediscovery Exhibition.
And this was the print I got.
I don't know...
I don't remember if I ever showed this to you guys.
On stream.
But this was the original canvas print that I got.
Here we go.
I got this one.
And I had it displayed in my apartment when I received it.
Because I love Guy Manuel so much.
Like, Guy Manuel...
Like, you have to love both equally.
And I was like, no.
I clearly have a favorite.
I...
So, I have this canvas print.
And it was like around $1,000.
Because they only had like, I think, $50?
They only like, sold $50 or so.
And I had to get this one.
I was like, it's so pretty.
And...
And also like, I have...
I actually have a replica of Guy Manuel's helmet.
And it has all the LED stuff.
So, it's like a mismatch of like, the 19...
Oh my gosh, I don't remember the helmet.
So, it's a mismatch.
Because it's not like an exact replica.
Because I love the LED stuff.
No, sorry.
Guy Manuel's original helmet.
With the smile.
Like, it can do like, rainbows.
And then the smiley.
And then the little like, the green like, heartbeat and stuff on the side.
But that is like, only one.
Like, oh my gosh, let's see.
Daft Punk.
Daft Punk helmet.
I wanted to show a picture.
But there's a reflection.
So, I can't.
Over the years.
Okay, let me...
It's been a while since I...
Look, they retired for a long time ago.
So, my helmet that I have.
It's not an exact replica.
Because I love the Discovery helmet.
So, let me give you guys.
I love the Discovery helmet.
The original Discovery helmet.
But also, I love the helmet design.
Of their newer helmets.
I can't believe it.
Okay, I need to like, make it smaller.
Because it's so big.
It's such a big file, guys.
I know this is supposed to be a chill working stream.
And like, there's a...
I started talking about Daft Punk.
So, I have to talk about...
Sorry, Tama.
I don't care.
So, my helmet that I have.
Is a...
It's basically...
Discovery helmet.
Mixed in with Human After All.
So, it has the wires from Human After All.
And then, the design and colors of Human After All.
But, it has the LEDs of Discovery.
So, because I love the LEDs feature.
Of the original helmet.
I also have the MediToys.
Of two of the Daft Punk figures.
And I have like...
I think I have the Tron one.
Sorry, they didn't make a Grammy.
I have the Tron one.
And the Tron cameo.
Sorry, I got the Tron cameo.
And the Grammy figures of them.
Which were really expensive back then.
Wait, let me see.
Let me see what they look like.
Tron Daft Punk figures.
I think they're called...
Oh, sorry.
MediCom.
Yeah, they're called MediCom.
These guys.
I have...
I have these figures.
And they're really hard to get.
Because they only made a super limited amount.
Guys, no, you don't understand.
I love them so much.
You don't...
I have these.
I have these figures.
And I also have the Grammy ones too.
And they're like...
How much?
Oh my god, they're $2,000 now.
Oh my god.
These figures are now $2,000.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Okay, they were not $2,000 when I first got them.
They were like...
I got them for retail.
I got them because...
I bought them in Hong Kong when they first came out.
And they were like retail prices.
Holy shit.
They're $2,000 now?
Oh my fucking god.
That's crazy.
Sorry.
Knowing that they're $2,000 now is actually insane.
Oh my god.
I did not get them for $2,000.
It's insane.
Okay, I also have this one too.
Apparently, these are $500 for one.
I also have these figures.
They're apparently now $500 for one of them.
But I have both of them.
And I also have...
I also have...
Which one is the...
Oh my god.
Where's the Grammy ones too?
I have the Grammy ones as well.
Where is it?
I need to find a better picture of the Grammy ones.
Is it mint?
They're all in their boxes.
I only took...
Well, the Tron one, I took them out for display.
This one is in their box because I never had time to take them out.
And I think the Grammy ones are also in the boxes as well.
Oh wait, I have this one.
Oh wait, no.
Do I have Random Access Memories or the Grammys?
I think I have the Random Access Memories.
No, I have RAM.
I didn't have the Grammy ones.
I had the RAM one.
So, this is the other one I have.
I have this one too.
I have these two.
And I don't know how much they are now.
But I have these guys as well.
And...
These guys, I know they're in their boxes.
I also have a replica of the triangle necklace that Guy Manuel wears as well.
Because I thought it was really cool.
And so I also have, like I said, the merch.
When they first did their store launch, I bought all their merch on their store launch.
So I bought the Daft Punk belt buckle.
And then I have all the prints they had on the store.
Like all the official store launch prints that they sold.
I see Daft Punk.
Store launch.
Merch.
Let me see if they still kept...
And the shirts too.
I had the shirts and everything.
I don't even know if they still have like...
Oh my god, this is what they had when they first launched the store.
And I bought like...
I bought like...
There's the patches.
The iron-on iron-on patch.
The shirts.
The prints.
The belt buckle.
And like...
I'm sorry, I had a problem.
Guys, you don't understand.
I take any crumb they'll give me.
You don't understand.
Every time...
They would like occasionally update their website.
To play with my heart.
Like...
Sometimes...
Sometimes they'll add something on the website.
And then I'll be like...
Is it a tab?
And then it's just...
They just try to milk their fans even more.
And then I fall for it every time.
I...
I let them milk me.
I take anything I can get.
I take anything they'll give me.
I'm just like a...
I laugh at Nintendo fans.
But I'm just like them.
But worse because my Oshi's dead.
My...
I'm worse.
My Oshi's dead.
And I'm still giving them my money.
I'm...
I'm still giving them my money.
Guys.
No.
They're dead.
Okay.
You were not there.
Alright.
I know some of you guys are like...
Were not there.
When they posted their retirement video.
They...
You were not there.
The retirement video that Daft Punk posted...
Was literally the two of them...
Fucking exploding.
Like...
Dude.
They actually fucking died.
Like...
And I fucking cried.
I was so sad.
They actually...
They actually self-destructed.
I was so sad.
You're like...
They're retired.
I was like...
No.
They're dead.
Like my heart.
Yeah.
So they used the clip from one of the movies they made.
That was like based off their robot personas.
And it's like...
The movie ends with them literally like...
Killing themselves by self-destructing.
And...
And I was like...
That's how they fucking...
And then they used that clip to basically be like...
We're retiring.
And I was like...
I thought that was just the movies.
It was never supposed to be real life.
I can't believe it.
It was never supposed to happen in real life.
I thought it
was...
They gotta have a backup somewhere.
They just...
They must have a backup.
Just install them a new body.
But yeah.
That was basically my...
Daft Punk obsession.
If they ever...
I don't know.
I don't want to have hope anymore in this world.
If they ever come back.
I don't know.
I try not to have too much hope in this world.
With them coming back.
I think...
I think it's better to be pleasantly surprised.
Than being crushed again.
Just like last time.
I'll take my Fortnite concert, guys.
I'll take my one piece of crumb.
That they'll give me.
And I'll be satisfied for another 10 years.
I'll be happy for 10 more years.
Let's just say.
Anyway, guys.
I realized there was no BGM.
So I'm gonna...
I'm gonna play some Nintendo...
Speaking of Nintendo.
I'm gonna play some Nintendo instrumentals.
Because we're not gonna be monetized on this.
They can have my advertising money.
They can have my ad money.
No, I'll be too distracted.
I'll cry if we listen.
After everything I went through today.
Blazing, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
I am a Daft Punk fan as well.
And was not old enough to see them live as well.
And I'm super excited for Daft Punk skins in Fortnite as well.
I was super sad when they broke up.
Also super happy to follow another fellow Daft Punk super fan.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I literally...
I literally saw...
The Tron movie.
Just for Daft Punk.
But then I fell...
I like...
Fell in love with the Rinzler design.
Cause like...
I don't know.
It's just something about the helmet.
It's like...
I only saw it...
When you find out who Rinzler is...
And you're like...
Put the helmet back on!
And you find out who he is.
Never take it off!
You're so cool with it.
Sorry, Rinzler.
You're so...
With the helmet.
The helmet stays on!
Yes, he did!
The flashback scene ruined it.
When you find out who he really is.
I'm like...
Never take it off!
It does.
It ruined my immersion.
It ruined my fucking immersion.
I didn't need to know who he was.
I just needed him to keep his helmet on.
That's all I wanted.
Like...
Not gonna lie.
I was not interested in...
Majority of the designs.
And the...
I wanna say Neutron movie.
The Tron sequel.
Because like...
Because they take off their helmets.
And then...
I don't know.
And then Clue was also pretty fucking weird.
But then when Daft Punk shows up...
I was like...
Yeah!
I'm here for you!
I'm here!
And then I was satisfied.
My 30 second cameo...
Made me happy throughout the movie.
The 30 second cameo...
Was enough for me.
That was...
Yeah.
That was enough for my entire movie.
My entire movie journey.
The best part...
Yeah.
And then I bought...
Obviously I have the movie soundtrack.
I bought the movie soundtrack and everything.
And I also have...
I have it on my phone as well.
I have the songs on my phone.
God, I love...
God, I love what they did with the soundtrack.
Um...
It was more like 5 seconds.
No!
They appeared again.
They were there for like 30.
Guys, you can see them in the corner.
In the corner of the background.
When they start fighting.
They could be like...
And then they start jamming to the music that they're making while they're fighting.
So it was like...
It was like 30 seconds.
They're like right there.
Oh yeah.
When Sook's song...
You know like...
I saw... You know how like...
Okay, I didn't watch the direct.
Um...
I didn't watch the direct...
Direct of the...
When they announced Sook's song.
And you know how I saw how everybody was freaking out about it.
So then I saw the clip.
It was nearly 5 seconds.
It was like...
A 5 second cut.
And then like...
I was like... Wait, that's it?
I was like...
Wait a minute.
That's it?
I thought...
And it was like an afterthought.
It's not like...
They didn't have their own feature.
It was just...
It was just an afterthought in the entire trailer.
Of like 20 other games.
The crumbs...
I'm just like you guys.
I'm just like you Nintendo fans.
But at least your game is still alive.
Uh...
5 seconds.
But I am full now.
5 seconds but I am full now.
So I'll talk about...
I know...
So I'll talk about.
This always happens when I do...
A working stream.
I never work because I just want to talk to you guys.
I'm starving.
I'm starving for social interaction.
Oh my god, I didn't realize the new Universal Park expansion opened like this week for like test previews.
Did you guys see it?
I saw so many clips of like the how to train your dragon island.
Um, um, that's at the, what was it called?
The, um, Universal, Epic Universal or whatever.
Yeah, yeah, I didn't realize that was a thing.
I didn't realize that was like being like built for like, how many years?
For like five years?
It was being built for five to six years.
No, it looks so cool.
I really want to just go to the how to train your dragon.
There's the how to train your dragon land looks amazing.
And they actually got like actors who sound just like yeah, the hiccup act.
Yeah, let me see if I saved.
Oh, I know like I sent it to a friend because I was like, oh my god, this is so cool.
And then like, they made the little dogs.
Um, you know, like the dog robots.
Um, what are they called?
The, the Boston dog robots.
They bought one of the Boston dog robots.
And like, yeah, they're doing test previews like this week or something.
And like, they put like a fucking dragon.
They made a dragon.
I'll show you guys.
Look, it's so cute.
Oh my god, that's that's literally the Boston dog robots right there.
And yeah, the Boston dynamic dogs for Toothless's kid.
And it's so fucking cute.
Oh my god, I was like, I was like, oh my god, what?
They're so interactive.
And then there's the one where you can do a meet and greet with hiccup and stuff and hiccup and Toothless and it's so cute.
Like I love the animatronics for it.
It's so cute.
Wait, let me see.
Epic universe.
Universe.
Okay, epic universe.
Let me see if I can find the clip of the hiccup one.
Okay.
Sorry, you might hear like clips of me trying to... Oh yeah, here's the, here's the hiccup actor for the meet and greet.
They actually have like this accent and everything.
I was so impressed.
I was actually and then the animatronic for Toothless looks really cool.
Yeah, I know I really want and then there's one with what's your hiccups his girlfriend?
I don't remember her name.
Or wife.
Sorry, they're married now.
But there's one with how long the animatronics are actually really, really cool.
I'm like so impressed by it.
Astrid.
Yeah, yeah, Astrid.
I'm just incredibly impressed with the, with the design and like the world building of everything.
It's just so cool.
I really want to go.
I know it's gonna be like super fucking, it's gonna be like super cramped and everything when it actually goes live.
Yeah, oh my god.
And then look at them.
They're so cute.
They're so tiny.
Oh my god, they're so cute and tiny.
Look at them.
Yeah, the lines.
I wish I was famous enough to be at the previews, the sneak previews.
God damn it.
Why am I virtual?
If I was made of flesh, they would have invited me.
I would be a theme park YouTuber for a day.
If I get to, if I get to see the test previews.
Then, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Someone made a free dragoon YouTuber model.
Do I have your blessing to try streaming it a bit?
Of course, of course you guys can.
You can use any of the free models.
Are they dragoon related?
Of course you can use it, because you're a dragoon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, oh my god.
I'm sorry, I'm just gushing over how cute they are.
I just, I wish I could, I haven't been to a theme park in so long.
Because like, I just hate lines.
I just, I hate, I hate, you don't understand.
I hate, I think everyone hates lines, but like, you don't understand.
I grew up so spoiled and sheltered that I never got, I never was raised to like experience, actually experiencing living through a line.
I hate, I was like, okay, so like, like, I was, I was a fast pass kid.
I, if it was possible, my parents and family would always get like the fast pass slash like bypassing all lines type shit, because like, like, they were not patient, and thus they raised a very impatient kid as well.
So, but I didn't do a lot of theme parks too growing up.
Um, so like, uh, I think, um, I've only, I know I went to Disney World when I was like, six or five.
Like, I think I only went to one American, like I went to one or two American Disneyland's, but I was like six or five.
So I don't even remember what the fuck I did there.
Like, I don't, and then the other experience I've had at a Disneyland was Hong Kong Disneyland.
And like, I don't know if you guys know that this, but Hong Kong Disneyland is very tiny, and it's so small that you can finish it within a day, especially if you just use, um, if you just use like the fast pass system.
It was, it, you do not stand in line for longer than like 10 to 15 minutes in Hong Kong Disneyland.
And, um, and, um, I think I went, I remember going to the Universal Park, like six years ago, but even then it was not that busy.
Because I think I was stood in line for like, I also was, was with some friends.
So I stood in line for like, at most like 15 to 20 minutes, because we were there during a not busy time.
So like, I never, I, I just didn't grow up with lines.
So I'll die in the line.
If you leave this cat in a line for 30 minutes or longer, she'll, she'll just, she'll, she'll just suffer a heart attack.
She'll die.
Perish.
Um, but yeah, I just never got a chance to go to like adapt to it.
So I got, I really, oh wait, no, I went to, I remember Tokyo Sea.
I went to Tokyo Sea, but that was when I was like seven.
Okay.
You know what's fucked up?
So I remember going to go to Tokyo Disneyland when I was a little, when I was a young bird.
And then I went there like twice and I wanted to go again because, okay, my family used to love to go to Japan a lot growing up.
I don't remember much from those trips though.
Cause I was super young.
Um, and then I wanted to go again.
I was like, Tokyo Disneyland.
And they were like, no Tokyo Sea because it's new.
And I was like, but I like, I don't like water.
I was like, but I don't like water.
Why do we have to go to Tokyo Sea?
I don't like water.
I remember I was crying in the tour bus cause, um, it was like a tour group.
And then one, we get to pick to go with the group that goes to Disneyland or the group that goes Tokyo Disneyland or the group that goes to Tokyo Sea.
And I was like, I want to go to Disneyland.
And my mom was like, no, we're going to Tokyo Sea cause we haven't been there before.
You went to Disneyland twice already.
And I was like, no!
I was crying in the bus.
I was like, no!
I want to go to sea!
I hate the ocean!
I was just like, I want to!
I don't like water!
I want to go to Disneyland!
And then, but I went to Tokyo Sea.
I don't remember much from it.
Like I said, I don't think I've ever went to, like, theme parks.
Like, other than Universal.
Universal was the last one I went to.
But like, I think that was the only theme park I went to where I'm like, you know, an adult now.
Where I'm like an adult.
So it's been a long time since I've experienced a theme park.
I think that's also because of COVID.
No, it's, yeah, it's because, also because of COVID too.
COVID sort of, COVID sort of like, you know, made people not go outside.
No, I don't, I never went to any roller coaster themed theme parks because I'm not a fan of roller coasters.
And I'm not that fan of roller coasters.
And I just prefer, I don't know.
I just, I like the world building of things.
And stuff, so.
I'm very limited to, like, some of the theme parks that, like, the rides that I want to go to.
Pearl Land?
Pearl Land is not a theme park.
It is an experience.
It is a lifestyle.
That doesn't count.
Pearl Land is a lifestyle.
It is an experience.
There's no theme park there.
It is a rite of passage for every Sanrio fan.
If you are a Sanrio fan, you have to go to Pearl Land.
But it is not a theme park.
It is like your indoctrination into the land of Sanrio.
And guys, we haven't been productive once at all during this stream.
It just, yes, it is like a pilgrimage.
It is a pilgrimage for all Sanrio fans.
Like, it is a requirement to go there.
Anyway, yeah guys, we haven't been productive at all.
We should really get going there.
We should really get started.
Guys, have you guys done anything while I was talking?
Because I sure haven't.
Nah, I mean, though, yeah.
Alright, let me look at my message.
I had like a lot of messages I had to go through.
Oh, fuck.
Oh yeah, I saw people were like, what happened to your... Okay, so, for the member goons, I'm sorry.
I got... I procrastinated.
Like, typical Doki fashion.
You know when you have like a lot of stuff going on and then you do none of them because you're just so overwhelmed?
That was me.
That was me last night.
And then, like, I did do some stuff because, like, okay, so, my manager has figured out a way that makes me more productive.
In a way that, like, I'll do like 30% of the to-do.
Like, 30% of the stuff I have to do.
Basically, every other day, he gives me a list and was like, at least do these things.
And I do like 30 to 40% of the list he gives me every day.
So, like, not every day, every other day.
That's why he gives me a to-do list every other day.
But it works.
But it works though.
It does work.
Yoko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I walked my dog and start cooking tomorrow's lunch.
Oh, good for you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I really wanna start being more healthier starting at least this week or next week.
I wanna start, like...
Well, not going outside more.
That's too much of a big step.
Baby steps.
Baby steps, everybody.
I wanna start...
I wanna start, like, doing more, like, being healthier in general.
So, like, exercising more and eating healthier and stuff like that.
And then, one of my friends was like, okay, one at a time.
Either you eat healthy or you exercise more.
Start exercising more.
Because...
It's trying to do both.
I know you're gonna give up.
It's like, let's not get too crazy.
So...
I don't know if I wanna start eating healthier first.
Maybe start eating healthier first and then we'll slowly do more and more exercising and stuff.
I do have, like, a treadmill in my apartment.
But I also have a building gym.
In my apartment complex, there is, like, their own gym.
So I was thinking... I feel like I'd be more motivated if I had to go downstairs to, like, the apartment gym.
And use the stuff there versus just using the treadmill in my own apartment.
But yeah.
I don't know what to start first, but I wanna try either this week or next week.
Just to be a bit more healthier.
Because I haven't been very healthy the last year, almost.
Just because, like, you know, lots of stuff was going on.
And then I was just, like...
I was eating my feelings away.
Or not.
I was either eating or not eating.
It was, like, a mix-match between the two.
And then, like...
Also, like, I'm always so fucking busy.
So it's hard to, like, get exercise in as well.
Because I've been, like, so fucking busy all the time.
I wanna start, like, slowly putting that into my scheduling as well.
I wanna start, like, introducing it back into my schedule.
Let's see.
Could get wallpaper that's darker sometime soon?
Yeah!
I think, like...
April's wallpaper will be...
The theme I chose for April will maybe be a darker wallpaper.
But I definitely will.
Thank you for the super chat, Tastyus.
Thank you, thank you.
I definitely want to go into more variety.
It's just the theming of each month was, like...
It didn't help as well.
Because the theming of each month was more so, like, bright colors and stuff.
Also, yes, I should...
The first thing I'll do, I'll post a member's wallpaper too.
For March.
I'll show you guys the outfit concept.
Outfit concept is always public.
But I love the outfit for...
I might...
I might ask...
This artist to design an outfit for me.
Because, like, I really love her outfit.
It's so cute.
Wait, let me...
I really love the outfit design for the Sakura...
For the March theme.
Let me see if I can find...
Okay, let me see where the file is.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Let me grab the file.
Alright, here's the character...
The concept art for it.
Woah, it's a big file.
Give me a sec.
Can I make it so that transform...
Fit to screen.
Is that it?
Oh!
How cute this outfit is, guys.
Wow!
Look at that.
It's such a cute outfit.
This is for...
This is for the March wallpaper.
I really like this outfit.
It's so cute.
I think I like the...
I just like...
I love the dress shirt combo.
It's really cute.
But yeah, this is the March wallpaper.
If you guys wanna...
I'll post the wallpaper now.
But if you guys wanna download the wallpaper for March...
Gotta join the membership.
I try to post the wall...
I try to have member wallpapers every month for us.
But yeah!
Wow!
I love the dress.
It's so cute.
Alright, let me...
Let me...
Post this real quick.
PNG.
There's the PNG.
There's the PSD.
Okay.
Download.
Did I download it?
Oh, I did.
Oh yeah, I need to upload this.
Okay, work time.
Work time.
In the right folder?
No.
Aww...
Where are my folders?
Kaiser, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Can we expect another drawing or profile pictures within the next six months?
Yes, Kaiser!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for reminding me.
Yes, we just had like...
I tried to make the member stream variety.
That's why we haven't had another part three of the profile pictures one.
Because I was trying to make sure there's varieties going on for the member stream.
But we'll definitely have another one within six months.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Trying to find where the wallpaper folder is.
So I can upload the newer wallpapers.
Oh, there you go.
Member wallpaper.
Let me rename this.
Gonna blow my nose.
Yeah, I'm still doing the ones from before times.
I've been like balancing between before times and current.
Bop bop bop.
Um, what did I name this?
File information.
Okay, members wallpaper for March.
Okay.
February, March.
Rename.
Members.
March wallpaper.
Yippee!
Share.
Link.
Okay, and I have to make the preview file too.
Yeah, it was supposed to be March, but then the artist was like...
Got sick, so she's gonna work on it in...
May.
Um, cause like...
I missed January's wallpaper.
So I missed January's wallpaper.
And she got sick, so her schedule got messed up a little bit.
So...
Um, she's gonna...
She's gonna work on it later.
Gladstone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Since you mentioned wanting to exercise more...
Here's hoping you can work your glutes muscles to the point you get the A...
The A-S-S and thighs that you can be proud of.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
GenXide, thank you for the super chat.
Um, working on a project for my class.
It's about gorilla marketing and I'm using you for one of my examples.
Also about to head into Home Depot to pick up some stuff for my...
For some stuff for my car.
I'm fabricating a wing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, hope you manage to...
Um, get all that done.
Hope you guys should be productive.
Not like me though, hehe.
Where did I put the wallpaper icon?
Wallpaper...
I have like...
Oh, there you go.
Wallpaper thumbnail.
I have like a specific thumbnail that I use for wallpapers.
February...
March wallpaper.
I forgot my schedule tonight.
I don't know what to do tomorrow.
March thumbnail.
Oh, I'll show you guys the thumbnail for it too.
This is the thumbnail.
It's cute.
Yay!
That's pretty cute.
I love working with Japanese artists.
Um...
Their work is so pretty.
I'll post this here.
And this is the March thumbnail.
The March wallpaper.
I always ask them to...
I try to get them to always include dragons for the wallpaper.
Cause like, I'm like, you're with me, you know?
I like having you guys there.
I think every wallpaper so far has you guys included.
Yeah, I'm looking through all the wallpapers and all of you guys are always like there.
This is not just me.
What is it?
Oh, maybe in the future.
I'll have a DoughKitty member's wallpaper next time.
Or not next time, whenever I contact them for the next couple of months.
Alright, let's see.
Oops, I accidentally closed it.
Who said no lube loser?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, post.
Members.
All channel members.
March, and then the concept art too.
It's not what I wanted.
Okay.
I'm trying to make it so the picture, the entire outfit shows on the...
...membership post thumbnail.
There it is, DoughKitty outfit.
Yeah, there it is.
Boom, boom, ba-dum, ba-dum, ba-dum, boom.
I know.
Yeah!
Okay, now I copy and paste what I wrote from before.
Edit.
It is... it is Sakura themed.
And...
Who did the art for this?
I'm gonna look up the artist again.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
This art.
This person.
Download here.
Share.
Okay, I have posted it!
Yay!
Alright guys, you can now download the wallpaper!
It has been posted, everyone.
If you are a member, good.
The March wallpaper is now out.
I posted it on the community post.
So you can download it now, guys.
Yippee!
It's super cute.
It's really, really cute.
I like the Sakura blossom.
Because I wanted a Sakura themed... wanted a Sakura themed wallpaper.
Whatever you want.
I have no preference.
Whatever you feel looks best.
I appreciate it.
Yeah, it's pretty cute.
I love the outfit.
I should make a tweet about it, too.
Yeah, I'm productive.
Look at that.
Okay.
Oh, Mac!
Thank you for the 5 gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
I should make this tinier, because it's covering me.
I'll put it here.
Like my little advertising space.
Let me just learn to show more.
I haven't been showing stuff as often.
Zekka!
Thank you for the 5 gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
I'll put it here.
I don't know.
Left or right?
Spanish or English?
Wow.
No, I think it's too crowded on the right.
I'll put it to the left.
Yeah, it's a little too crowded.
Alright.
Let me make my tweet.
Also, I'm so sad.
I don't know if Twitter's broken or like...
I mean, Twitter's always broken.
I don't fucking know what to do.
Who am I kidding?
Twitter's always broken.
But I don't know if you guys noticed.
The media tab is like fucked up right now on Twitter.
So like you can't scroll past 15 images.
And you have to keep like...
If you want to scroll past 15 images, you have to keep refreshing over and over and over again.
It's so fucking annoying.
I'm just...
It's...
It's so annoying.
I hate it so much.
Yeah.
I have no idea what's going on.
Work, work, work, work, work.
Mike, thank you for the gifted chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Angrius, thank you for the super chat.
Getting ready for this year's Sage I'm Sad?
There's another one this year?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I haven't...
I really... I don't know.
I don't know.
I'm not sure.
Is Sage I'm Sad another one?
Cause like I did the Sage I'm Slam based off of vibes.
And I guess like the game as well.
Cause like...
I'd rather be on the team that I vibe with the most.
You know?
And it's based off of like... And also if I'm not super overworked too.
Because like Kony was telling me how like...
How he felt he was like so overworked with everything.
Because he joined Twitch Rivals and the Sage I'm Slam at the same time.
So he had no time to practice.
So he chose Twitch Rivals in terms of practicing over...
Over... Cause like he practiced more for the Marble Rivals tournament.
Over like...
What game were they playing that time?
Was it Street Fighter as well?
It was Street Fighter, right?
It was Street Fighter.
So it really depends on like the time too.
I don't know.
It depends on the...
It depends on who the people are that signed up.
And also like...
It's just like vibes for me.
I enjoy Sage I'm Slam.
I enjoy like...
I enjoy the vibes from the Sage I'm Slam more than like...
The competitive side.
Oh, I'm munching on a cough drop.
And the timing well too.
Yeah, and the game.
Game as well.
But yeah, there's a lot of factors that go in.
Alright.
Sorry, I blanked out.
Because I was like, what do I have to do next?
Oh, yeah.
I was trying to post my wallpaper.
The boy who falls...
Fails.
Sorry.
The boy who fails.
Welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome.
Exposed.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Everyone shall know that I'm watching this at 144p while being on top of the Eiffel Tower eating a baguette with a...
That's how you spend your Tuesday morning.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Wallpaper.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
I have to search up my old tweets.
That's how fucked up it is.
I...
Like, I have to use the search function because I can't...
I can't use my media tab.
I am not refreshing my media tab like 20 times just to find my old membership.
My old, like, wallpaper posts.
Sub Sharky.
Thank you for the five gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Alright, there you go.
I found it.
Yay!
Okay.
There's the march.
It still sucks that I have to, like, search this up every time.
Bottom, bottom, bottom.
Wallpaper.
And then, I always do, like, the outfit.
Download the...
March wallpaper.
Alright, where's the...
Where's my community post?
There it is.
Wait, no, that's not it.
Post.
This one?
No, it should be Eugene.
Okay, does this work?
Yay, it worked!
Okay, I'm gonna tweet it out now.
And then, bonus outfit concept.
Oh, let me fix that.
Defected, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Greetings from Japan, Doki.
So, it's Wednesday morning!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Good morning over there on the other side of the world.
Morning!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Cheat secure.
Is there one I wanna upload?
Or is it this one?
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Which one did I name it as?
I don't remember.
Oh, it's character sheet Sakura.
Is it?
Oh, it is.
Uh...
More balls!
Thank you for the 10 gifted shares!
Thank you, thank you!
And Chris, thank you for the 5 gifted shares!
I really appreciate it, guys.
Thank you so much!
Alright.
Alright, I'm tweeting about...
March wallpaper now.
Yippee!
Post all.
That should work, right?
Yay!
Okay.
What's that have to do?
Uh...
Alright, let me answer my Discord messages now.
Um...
Oh yeah, I need to set up my account to be paid.
That's important.
My manager is like, remember to set up this account so you can be paid for your sponsor.
Yay!
That's something I gotta do.
I gotta do that.
Okay.
Text me.
Alright,
um...
I'm...
Okay, I am a corporation.
Yes.
Yay, it works!
Yippee!
Okay.
Okay, I was really scared...
Cause like...
Okay, so...
Without like...
Doxxing myself...
Okay, it's not really doxxing, but like...
I have to use bill.com for one of my...
So like, this is business talk.
So I have to use bill.com for one of my sponsors to be paid.
And like, they had to send...
Um...
I tried to like...
Uh...
Log in via...
Google.
For the account.
Because bill.com is like...
Mostly for American payments.
So like, I got really...
So when I tried to log in...
Um...
Via like...
My...
Like my...
Via Gmail, like via Google.
It wouldn't let me put in my company's address.
Which is Canadian.
So I got really confused.
I was like...
What?
It's only...
It's like locked into American.
So, but like...
The thing is...
The only way Canadian companies...
Can like...
Register to bill.com...
Is if they send you an invite...
And you have to create an account...
On there.
You can't log in via Google.
Uh...
Via Google.
You can use your Gmail and create an account.
But you log in...
Via your Google account...
It locks it to an American address.
So...
So I had to have them...
Send me a new invite...
To a different email.
So I can create a Canadian account...
On that website.
It's so fucking...
It is so weird.
So I have to...
So I...
So I have to like...
Go through like several hoops for it.
Yeah.
No, bill.com is like...
It's like supposed to be like...
Only American addresses.
Unless...
Unless like you get invited.
Um...
Business type.
I am a corporation.
Uh...
Media and entertainment industry.
Um...
Services.
I'm providing a service.
I use QuickBooks.
QuickBook Online.
Alright.
Yeah, I'm a company technically.
Um...
Cause it's easier...
For taxes.
Tax reasons.
It's also like...
Easier to deal with.
And then like...
Um...
Paying via my company...
Is like...
Easier...
It's like...
What's the word?
Logistic wise?
Logistic wise, it's like...
Less...
Mentally draining.
It's just simpler to deal with.
Logistically.
I don't think you guys...
I feel like a lot of you guys don't know this...
But a lot of VTubers...
Actually have their own...
Or like...
Have their own like...
Like not company company...
But they register their VTubing activities...
As their own business.
So a lot of them have their own like actual...
Business business.
Because like...
It's just easier to...
Like...
Um...
Especially when you're getting paid.
Yeah, LLCs.
Yeah.
A lot of like VTubers have like...
Or entertainers.
Or content creators.
Um...
Use like...
LLC or like...
Incorporated.
I'm incorporated.
It's just...
Easier in terms of like...
Taxes and branding.
Yeah.
Like even like...
Indies too.
I know like a lot of...
Indies and...
Corporate VTubers.
A lot of Indies and corporate VTubers...
Are registered under a...
Um...
Under like an...
Under like an LLC or...
A company.
Like their own com...
Like their own company.
So when they get paid...
It's just easier to...
Have it go through...
The company.
Versus go through themselves.
Yeah.
It's like...
Recommended too.
Uh...
Weeb.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I just saw...
The funniest title for a stream called...
Helping Doki not be...
A pain.
Weeb.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wings.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
As IT...
Trying to incorporate both American and Canadian addresses...
Is such a pain.
That usually an entire new system...
Is just made for one or the other.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Yeah.
It is.
It's pretty painful.
Um...
I feel like it's...
Like coding-wise...
There's a lot to go into it.
Um...
Maddie.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How much is a share of Doki Bird Incorporated?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I own all the shares.
So...
I'll never go public.
In the current stock market?
Are you fucking crazy?
Like...
Thank you.
This is the time where you don't go public.
Like...
I saw...
Bro...
In the current economy...
In the current stock market...
Why the fuck would you ever right now?
Bro, it's so...
Bro...
The scariest part is that apparently America's stock...
America's stock market has not opened yet.
But you can see the rest of the world...
That's so scary.
It's like...
America's slowly watching each country opening their stock market before...
Before the time zone catches up right now.
Like...
It's like...
NA...
NA and EU's just looking at what's going on in Asia and they're like...
And it's like...
Like a...
A fucking...
It's like a pandemic, you know?
And then you can see it's like a zombie apocalypse.
And you see it slowly approaching you.
It's like...
It's slowly approaching you right now.
You're like...
It's almost opening time.
Oh my god.
And you can't do anything right now.
All you can do is watch.
All you...
Um...
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
CEO's can see when.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
React, thank you for the super chat.
Um...
Hohoho, I died for this.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I want you to escape from reality.
We blame Medi.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
One Doki Bird stock, please.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Hmm...
Let's see.
Oh yeah, I need to...
What's my register address?
Nobody special.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's see...
I don't remember my address.
Like, for my business.
Because it's different.
Uh...
Let's see.
I pinned it somewhere.
I pinned it with my manager's chat.
I just put all the most important information in my chat with my manager.
So I can...
Uh...
I just...
So like, he has all the information.
And then I have all the information too.
Uh...
Mr. Stan!
Thank you for the Aka Super!
Ah!
Thank you, thank you!
Can I get a few stock in Toki Brand Incorporated, please?
Ah, yes.
The VTuber market is where the stock won't crash.
The smartest investment is right here.
Everything is crashing.
But not...
Not this market.
They're too big to fail!
The bubble's not gonna pop, guys!
Thank you for the Aka Super!
Thank you, thank you!
Medi, thank you for the super chat!
Uh...
I like to scrub my last super chat from the record, your honor!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright.
Let's see...
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Oh!
Let me leak you the next merch item that's being worked on.
Ha-ha-ha-ha.
I don't mind leaking this.
So, at least you guys can save up for it.
Knowing that...
It'll be like...
Sometime in the future.
So, it won't be a surprise and be like...
I don't have money now!
So...
Um...
I noticed that...
You know, we have a lot of plushies.
You know?
We have a lot of plushies being released.
But...
We don't...
This one's different.
Have you...
I noticed that a lot of you guys...
What you guys miss the most...
Is a portable plushie.
Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha.
You know like...
A mini...
The pup...
Not...
Well, they're not puppets.
But the mini plushies that...
You can like...
Bring around with you and everything.
Yeah, so that's being worked on right now
It's like, you know, it's like, you know, it's like, okay, so I specifically requested that The mini ones I want them.
I want them so you could put clothes on them.
So like the hats and hoodies and stuff So, you know how there's like Sanrio hoodies and stuff like that where you can like put like those little costumes and stuff like that On top of your plushie.
So I specifically requested to have it so that you can To be sized in a way where you can put like actual outfits on it because I was remembering my old my old plushies where you'd like people would like put Cosmetics and little design outfits on it or buy like outfit clothes for their plushie and stuff and I thought it was really cute I wanted to be in the perfect size that you can put like a little hood and everything So you can you like these guys,
so I made it.
I asked that the plushie is Sized the same size as these hoodies So you put like these little these little official hats and stuff from other puppets other like miniature plushies So you put it on top of her Yeah, you're dress up doki, yeah, it's gonna be um,
I think it's 10 centimeters, let me look
I'm trying to remember what the size is.
I think it's 10 centimeters I'm checking I think it's 10 to 15 centimeters.
Yeah, I think it's 10 to 15 centimeters They're gonna be 10 centimeters and stuff so They're gonna be tiny They're gonna be like the puppets basically the puppet size I'm also designing a hood for it too.
I asked to make it.
I asked them to design a Dragoon hoodie like a little these types of hoodies like a custom one So I asked them to make a dragoon and a dad hoodie too so you can dress dress your doki up But you know put that on other plushies.
Yeah, I Don't know how long how long it's gonna take though It's not gonna be like soon soon
Eventually it would be eventually
No, the the body is printed on so like if you know like the miniature plushies The body itself is printed on So the outfit doesn't come off cuz they're tiny
I'm super excited though.
It's so cute.
I Love the con like they showed me a preview of the concept art.
Yeah, it's gonna be a 10 cm plushie And it's enemies like I said, there's like the portable ones where you can take them around everywhere and take photos of it and everything Like they're not just meant for display You can actually bring them around and then you can fit them in your those little like oh She bags and stuff though.
Oh the plushie.
Oh, she bags
Yeah, they eat the bags
Up up up up up what I have to do next.
Oh, yeah, so I'm fixed.
I finished my
Scene the build comm registration, which is like the most important part next please Tell us about me
Senior I am the CEO Your CEO I
Mean I'm the BOM business operation manager.
Oh wait.
I'm the CEO.
Why is there no is there no occupation?
Oh It's chat dead.
Oh, no, I'll fix it.
Don't worry.
I can fix this
Yeah, it should be fixed now
Uh Wings thank you a super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Imagine trying to pay dividends only to see them get sent back via super chats only Papa YouTube Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you Sapphire Sapphire.
Thank you a super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Doki coin or dad coin will save us financially through the decades 2030s ain't ready for us.
Don't you stop?
Here we go.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Papa smart.
Thank you for the super chat Thank you.
Thank you my dress up.
Don't you?
Smug Nova, thank you a super chat.
Thank you.
I will be buying.
I will be throwing it to the wall affection Thank you.
Thank you.
I'm super excited.
My merch store is being working on being worked on right now.
Um And like I'm super excited about like some of the Products that's gonna be on there.
I asked if they could like make it so Some of the products I'm having on there.
It's not it's gonna be there forever type deal.
So it's not gonna be like limited sales for the launch I
put myself as like a business I'm not self-employed.
I'm like you need the owner of my own business.
I Put myself as a business operate guys.
I need help.
Do I put myself at the business operation?
I mean, I'm everything I'll just put myself as business operation manager.
Well, technically, I'm not everything but like I don't know I Mean there's no CEO in there.
It's just
I'm not self-employed.
I have employees Is it what?
Can I put self-employed if I'm like the CEO because I do have employees in it
Like okay, here are the options.
Yeah, I'm my own employee Yeah, okay.
I'm gonna put it cuz they have other management.
I just put other management role I'll put other at management role No, it's like I'm being paid I'm just gonna put other management role there's no owner in there It's like business operation analyst business operation manager finance manager financial investment analyst financial auditor Or accountant general manager IT administrator legal attorney notary advisor marketing associate marketing manager public relations manager sales manager sales representative Self-employed senior managing Official and other management role or self-employed the CEO.
Okay, next please.
Okay, I get it.
I did put my city.
That's my city.
Do they not rep... do they not see my city?
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna add my Canadian bank account.
Imagine he's gonna be so proud of me that I did this live on stream.
Is he gonna be so proud of me and I didn't leak any details.
He's gonna be so proud.
Yay!
Oh, what's my password?
I have like a million tabs open right now.
What
card is this one?
Oh.
Which... which one is this one?
I don't know how to look at my bank.
I don't know which account this one is.
Is it this one?
No, it's not.
Okay, it's this one.
Hope this is the right account I'm looking because then it'd be awkward.
Connect to my bank, please.
You're getting verification data.
It's loading.
Where's my tissue?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
I was gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back, guys.
I gotta use the bathroom.
I'm back.
What the fuck?
It says my credential's not correct.
Okay, no, that can't be right.
I think I need like... Oh, it might be different.
Okay, that'll be awkward.
Alright, I'm gonna add.
Maybe it's this?
Oh, no.
Okay, copy.
Paste.
Continue.
Also, Mehdi, Solid, Zekra, Allen, MorphBoss, Bitesize, Johnny, Mike, Smug, and JL.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Please, please connect.
Why you no connect?
Oh, no.
It's not.
Oh, come on.
It's getting verification data.
Come on.
Connect.
Please.
That's all I want.
Or else I'm gonna get paid.
Did it work?
Oh, it's still working.
Stay with us.
Okay.
They're getting a verification to try to connect to my bank account.
My corporate bank account.
What?
Huh?
Hey, what the fuck?
Why is it not connecting?
Oh, that's not good.
Why is it not connecting to my bank account?
But I literally logged in.
I logged in.
I'm literally in the account right now.
I'm in my bank account.
That doesn't make sense.
I'm literally in the account.
It's okay, I can fix this.
Yeah, that's the password.
Okay.
Okay, guys, this is...
I'm gonna try this again.
Yeah, that's correct.
Yeah.
I fucking hate this bank.
I hate... I hate this bank!
Actually...
I hate this bank so much.
And I have like a bank teller that like, recognize...
Okay, remember when I told you guys the story about that bank teller that asked me if I was JokieBee?
And then like, I didn't go back to the bank for months.
I didn't go back to that bank for fucking months.
And then I went back because I needed to do a Y transfer and I didn't want to go far.
So I came back and I saw him there.
I saw that guy there.
So I purposely like, left the line like, in the middle of the line because I counted.
And I was like, oh my god, I'm gonna have to go to that guy again.
And then...
And then I left the line and then I went out, walked around, came back to line up and I still got him.
I still...
And then I... I... Oh my god, it worked.
Oh my god, it worked.
Okay, and then I... And then I like...
Approached the desk and then before I gave him my card, he was like, is this for... Is this for Doki?
Like, Doki Braid?
And then I was like, oh my god, I didn't come back for months.
And now I'm... Now I don't go back.
I'm avoiding the bank again.
I didn't go back.
Oh my god.
That is just crazy.
I... Also, I'm... Sorry, I need to grab the code.
I looked away, so I need the code.
I have a two-factor verification because it has a lot of money in there.
Oh my god.
He has to pretend he doesn't know who I...
He has to pretend he doesn't know who it's for.
It's not taxes!
I'm trying to like, register an account to get paid for a sponsor.
You're watching me get paid right now.
I'm trying to get paid.
Meemen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is maybe the first time you're watching a YouTuber do their taxes on stream.
Johnny Lacone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My host, she hates banks.
Let's go.
Wait, what?
We connected to your financial institution, but couldn't find an eligible checking or savings account for money movement.
However, other...
What do you mean?
Are you fucking this bank so much?
I hate this.
Oh my god, I hate this.
I hate this bank.
I, I...
Oh my god.
I actually, I...
You have no idea how much I fucking hate this bank so much.
Like, it has brought me more pain than...
Oh my god.
I, I...
Oh my god, why did I...
Oh, why did I use this bank for my business?
This fucking bank.
Oh my god.
Apparently, it's not eligible to receive money.
I do.
I have a USD...
I have a USD account.
I have a USD account in my business account.
So, I have a USD and a Canadian...
I have a USD and a Canadian account to accept both.
Because I only...
I usually, when I work with companies outside of Canada, I only accept US dollars.
Because no matter what, even the economy might be crashing soon.
Let's hope not.
But like, no matter what, American money will always be worth more than Canadian money.
So, our money is not doing...
Our currency will never do well.
No matter what happens, I know American money will always be worth more than the Canadian money.
So, that's why...
That's why, like, I have to...
Let's see.
Oh, you don't understand.
Our paper money is...
Unless our new prime minister...
Like, I don't know.
Okay, the only way I can see it is that our prime minister...
Oh, wait.
Fucking pull is a miracle.
Like, I don't know.
Cuts off the United States from the body.
Just...
Because we're connected.
So, like, if something happens to America, it happens to us.
Like, it doesn't matter.
It's like, you know, okay.
So, it's like we're like conjoined twins, basically.
Also, like...
Sorry, I have to use the code.
That's why I'm AFK.
We're like conjoined twins.
So, like, you know...
You know how, like, if one conjoined twin...
Because we're all...
We share organs.
So, if one...
One of the...
Because we share organs.
So, if the other twin dies, like, it fucks over the other person because, you know, you're dead.
But we still share the same bloodstream, the same organs, and stuff like that.
So, like, if anything happens to America, we get, like, collateral damage.
Just because we're connected.
So, like, whatever happens, it happens.
Alright, getting verification data.
Okay, let's see if this works.
It's not eligible!
I fucking...
I hate...
I...
Oh my God!
I hate my bank.
I hate...
I have to manually add.
I have to manually add!
I have to...
Oh my God.
I can accept American dollars!
Okay, I have to manually add my...
I can't do it automatically, apparently.
Okay.
Okay, this entire stream will be me figuring out this bill.com shit.
Let's see...
JL, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Everything may be going to hell in handbasket, but at least I have Dogekiddy here.
To have anxiety attacks, or diabetes attacks from LQ shoes.
Yay!
As long as we have anime girls, everything will be okay, guys.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Yippee!
Let's escape our problems together.
Okay.
This is the account name!
It's literally...
Oh my God.
It's my business name!
Oh my...
Okay.
All right, whatever.
Whatever.
That's fine.
Uh...
Business...
Oh my God, my OBS disconnected.
Hello, am I back live?
Am I back live?
Did it reconnect?
It just says OBS connection.
Uh...
Okay, thank you.
All right, welcome back.
Okay.
Uh...
Yeah!
Yeah.
It got cut briefly.
Even my internet was going through it right now.
Okay, I'm not in the stream until I figure this fucking build.com shit.
I will not name my bank.
Because I don't want to...
I don't want...
I don't want them to be mad at me.
Hahahaha!
I fucking hate this bank so much.
I...
Okay.
Uh...
Where is my bank number?
There it is.
I don't know why.
I should have picked a different bank.
We don't have a lot of options, guys.
Hahahaha!
Okay,
what is my...
Is this for a Canadian?
We don't have a lot of bank...
Good bank options.
But apparently the one I chose was the worst one.
Oh my god!
I'm forced to...
Oh my god, I'm forced to be paid in Canadian dollars.
No, they can't do this to me.
I refu...
Hahahaha!
I refuse to accept Canadian money.
No, please.
Hahahaha!
You don't understand.
Nobody wants to accept Canadian money.
Hahahaha!
They can't do this to me.
Don't make me accept this.
Okay.
Does this work?
I have to verify...
Okay, guys.
I have to verify my email now.
Hahahaha!
They're like...
Please!
Okay.
Where does it say...
Oh.
Where?
How's my email not verified?
Are you fucking...
No, you cannot.
Okay.
Please try again.
What the fuck do you mean my email address has not been verified?
Like, what do you mean?
Hahahaha!
Oh my god.
There's no way.
There's no...
They didn't even...
Nope, nope.
It's not in my trash.
It's not in my spam.
There's no way.
Like...
What do you mean my email has not been verified?
I don't understand.
Don't do this to me right now.
I'm gonna fucking freak out.
I'm...
Don't do this to me.
I'm mad.
Oh, don't do this to me.
There's no verification anywhere!
Just let me get paid!
Please, I just...
I just want to get paid.
Please.
All right.
I'm checking my junk.
There's nothing in junk.
Oh my god.
Do I have to put my Canadian money?
I swear to god.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I'm gonna put my Canadian money bank account.
See if that works.
Please.
Please, for the love of god.
It's like email address has not been verified.
But like...
They never send me anything!
They never send me a thing to verify my email.
So, what do you want from me?
What do you want from me?
Okay.
It's okay.
I'm okay, guys.
I'm okay.
Everything is fine.
Everything...
I feel so healthy.
Mentally.
I...
Never send me a verification email.
I don't understand.
How do I verify something if they don't even give me an email to verify it?
How?
I never got a verification email.
Please, make it make sense.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go crazy.
It won't let me fucking get...
Oh my god.
I need help.
It's uneven.
I can't get past this!
They won't let me get past this part.
Please.
I just want to get paid.
Please, for the love of god.
Just pay me.
That's all I want.
Okay, so there's two options if I can't get the build.com set up.
They mail me a check, which I feel so safe about.
Or they do PayPal.
The thing is, I do PayPal.
PayPal takes a percentage off of it.
So, of course, I would go with...
I would go with something where I get like the full deposit.
So, I was like...
I do not feel very safe with the check option.
So, I'm not going with that.
Okay.
All right.
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
I'm gonna fucking freak out.
I...
Okay.
Company address.
Don't worry.
I got this, guys.
Okay, I think I figured it out.
Hello?
No, you don't do this to me.
No, you don't.
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
Everything is okay.
I might have to ask them to mail me a check.
I...
Oh my god.
Okay.
We sent you an email with verification link.
Oh my god.
They sent me an email.
Resend email, please.
You've never sent me an email.
Send it to me again, please.
Okay, now I wait.
There's no way it takes that long to send me an email.
There's no way.
Oh my god, how long does this take?
How...
No, it's the right email.
I'm literally logging in to the right email.
I only have one email connected to it that I created to log in to build.com.
Oh my god.
Confirm.
Confirm my email address right now.
My email has been verified.
I have successfully verified my email.
Oh my...
Oh my god.
It has been done.
Did I do it?
Oh my god.
I connected my account.
My fucking god.
Please do not pay me in.
I beg of you, do not pay...
Oh no.
Do not pay me in Canadian, please.
Don't pay me in this.
My dog shit currency.
Let me...
Let me connect my American account.
Okay.
Add your United States dollar bank account to receive payments through what?
Make sure to only add accounts located...
Okay.
Okay, there we go.
Maybe I'll...
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna try and see if I can add my American account.
Please.
You know the worst part?
Is that they're originally paying...
They're originally paying in American.
So they're gonna have...
The currency trans...
There's gonna be a fee in my Canadian bank account.
Because they have to transfer the American money to Canadian.
But then the bank takes a fee and...
Doing the currency trans...
Like, the currency...
The...
Transition.
So I need to...
I need to make sure...
I need to make sure it goes directly...
Conversion, sorry.
Currency transition.
The currency transition.
I'm sorry, my brain's not working.
The currency conversion fee.
So I'm trying to make sure it goes directly to my American account.
So it doesn't go through the exchange.
There's so many hoops.
When I say I hate my bank, I hate my...
JR, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
They put me through so much.
Okay.
Account number.
Alright.
Where is the transit number?
There it is.
Okay, this should work.
Text me my code.
Alright.
Trust this computer.
Did it work?
Save.
Oh my god!
I did it.
I fucking... I fucking did it.
Okay.
Okay, I have a united...
Okay, I added...
Okay, I did it.
But why is it still trying to send me an...
Oh my god, why is it...
Stop, don't...
I swear to god, if they send me an...
Okay.
Oh my god, I did it.
I...
God.
Oh my god, I fucking did it.
Oh, I have...
Guys, I did...
Guys, I got my USD account in there.
I don't know if it works though.
I don't... I don't know if it...
If it's...
If it's accepted it.
But like, I've added it.
Oh my god, I fucking did it.
Okay, now all I need to do...
Is accept the invoice.
Okay.
Okay, it created it.
Okay, does it go directly?
Oh, I hope this goes directly to my USD account.
Oh dear lord, I hope it does.
I would be very sad if it doesn't.
I will be very sad if this doesn't.
Okay.
All right.
I've sent it.
Okay.
All right.
I don't know if this is...
Okay, I...
It could... I fucking... I don't know.
It's been done.
Guys, all right.
I think that's been a productive day.
I did at least two things today.
I...
Let's hope I received the money.
I think I did.
The build.com was...
It was a fucking struggle.
So I hope I received my money.
All right, guys.
I'm gonna call it here.
I hope you guys had a great time hanging out with me today.
I always have a great time hanging out with my dragoons.
I hope you guys enjoyed this guerrilla stream.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna head off now.
I'm gonna do some Rivals grind off stream.
And see if we get top 500 today.
For the Shiny Sparkle Badge.
And I'll do my schedule too today.
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!